neustart nachdem corona lockdown
lissabon begrüßt seine besucher lasst
uns darüber gehen und die aussicht
genießen für nun oder paula ist es die
erste tour seit monaten und endlich
wieder eine perspektive für den
stadtführer der bekannt ist für seine
guten tipps heute ist ein perfekter tag
die sonne scheint und wir sind fast ganz
allein an diesem wunderschönen platz die
beiden frauen aus der schweiz haben sich
spontan für diesen trip entschieden ein
paar tage ausspannen ohne familie das
nun in seine stadt zeigt als seien sie
freunde gefällt ihnen besonders
wir werden einfach so allein die stadt
erkunden gegangen aber dann denkst du
dir zeit so ein bisschen mehr und machst
eine private führung es macht mir jetzt
auch nicht jeden tag aber man tut dann
vielleicht dann auch was gutes an den
blick auf das verborgene lenken fernab
der touristen hotspots bereits vor der
pandemie hat nur diesen weg
eingeschlagen nun will er ihn wieder
aufnehmen
die menschen haben momentan angst vor
großen massenaufläufen selbst wenn wir
alle geimpft sind wird es noch eine zeit
lang dauern bis sie sich wieder unter
vielen menschen aufhalten wollen
deshalb wird es nur mehr von diesen
persönlichen tun geben an orte die eben
nicht voll mit besuchern sind diese art
von tourismus sollten wir vielmehr
machen
lissabon gehört zu den beliebtesten
zielen in europa der tourismus wird
schon bald wieder an fahrt aufnehmen und
für neuen auch schon sorgen
nachdem wochenlang niemand ins land
einreisen durfte portugal stand kurz vor
dem corona kollaps eine der höchsten
instanzen weltweit statt ferienflieger
kamen die maschinen der bundeswehr mit
medizinischer hilfe
er ist ein strenger locker und konnte
die zahlen schließlich senken
nun kehren die touristen zurück doch
gleichzeitig wächst die sorge dass die
altstadt mehr und mehr zur reinen
fotokulisse wird louis mendes ist statt
geograf beobachtet die veränderungen
seit jahren die die noch hier leben
klagen nachbarn ziehen weg kleine
geschäfte schließen
hier gibt es nichts mehr noch nicht mal
mehr einen kleinen tante emma laden und
der von donna manuela klar ist auch
umgezogen
hier in der alfama seien bereits 60
prozent der wohnungen in
ferienunterkünfte umgewandelt worden
die mieten haben sich innerhalb weniger
jahre verdreifacht teilweise sogar
verzehnfacht
einheimische verdrängt die folgen hat
nicht zuletzt die pandemie zu tage
gebracht ohne touristen war die stadt
plötzlich menschenleer druckfertig alles
was das viertel ausmachte wurde
verändert und zielte nur noch auf die
bedürfnisse der touristen
seitdem ist diese gegend hier nicht mehr
widerstandsfähig stattdessen abhängig
von äußeren einflüssen in den sternen
wie schwer es ist diese entwicklung
umzukehren erlebte lissabon politik
derzeit mit einem programm
ferienwohnungen selbst anzumieten und
günstige an einheimische weiter zu
vermieten
das hat bislang nicht funktioniert weil
man nicht genügend vermieter gefunden
hat die das machen wollten
wir haben 20.000 airbnb ist dieser zeit
fast vollständig leer stehen aber nur
200 wohnungen bzw deren eigentümer für
das programm gewinnen können
er kennt diese angebote martin starter
besitzt acht ferienwohnungen hat sie
selbst renoviert und dekoriert und wie
er sagt damit auch dazu beigetragen dass
die häuser nicht mehr so runtergekommen
sind an die stadt zu vermieten kommt für
ihn nicht in frage wenn jetzt drüber
gesprochen wird es gibt so viele
touristen muss man nur mal schauen wie
es jetzt ausschaut wenn man keine
touristen haben
jetzt will jeder wieder die touristen
weil ohne touristen lissabon einfach
erstmal total leer ist und das leben
fehlt auch das pulsierende leben in der
straße eine stadt im zwiespalt auch nun
oder paula ist auf die touristen
angewiesen hätte beinahe den job
verloren keine kunden über monate seine
agentur musste die fahrzeugflotte
verkaufen
nun sind sie froh dass es nach der
existenziellen krise wieder losgeht
und wie war's gut fühlte sich an wie der
erste schultag
sie wollen in den nächsten monaten
weitere orte ins programm nehmen langsam
das unternehmen wieder aufbauen
doch dabei nicht ihr prinzip aus den
augen verlieren touren gezielt an die
wünsche der kunden anzupassen flexibel
zu bleiben
ich glaube dass viele leute wieder
verreisen wollen und sich dann aber
bewusst ziele aussuchen die draußen
sende in der natur oder einfach
individueller persönlicher
[Musik]
es ist ein nachdenklicher neustart auch
für barbetreiber rodrigo felix er hat
sein lokal erst vor wenigen wochen
eröffnet besinnt sich auf das regionale
wird vor allem authentisch seien keine
show für touristen als wir hier in
portugal im lockdown waren waren die
gezwungen mehr auf uns selbst zu schauen
wir haben dieses fade lokal eröffnet und
uns darauf konzentriert was uns selbst
gefallen würde wenn wir in ein vater
lokal geben und so kehrt er zu dem
zurück was viele an lissabon so lieben
das ungezwungene alltagsleben in den
gassen und cafés für die beiden
schweizerinnen strahlt die stadt an
diesem abend vor allem eines aus leute
haben sicherlich unter der pandemie
gelitten
das sehen sie auch und sind jetzt völlig
einig rom gehen besucher hier in der
stadt
nach monatelangem stillstand kehren nun
die zurück die sich nach statt urlaub
und siegen sehen eine chance für dieser
bond sich in zukunft neu zu erfinden
[Musik]